bonjour c'est fabien du futur en de
fabien du futur c'est qui c'est celui
qui a déjà tourné la vidéo que vous
allez voir mais on a perdu le début de
cette vidéo un loïc oui on l'a perdue
parce que on a mal copié la carte sd sur
l'ordre
on n'a pas de chance quand même non mais
rassurez-vous il manque rien du tout du
casse tête il manque que juste l'intro
que je vous expliquer qu'il ya cinq mois
on a on a fait ses camions
on a fait vous et moi ensemble le
comparatif entre le casse tête à neuf
euros à 130 euros eon de faire celui à
270 euros il n'a pas été fait parce
qu'ils n'avaient pas le temps eh bien on
le fait là aujourd'hui
j'en profite aussi pour répondre à une
question qui revient régulièrement dans
les commentaires il y aura un autre gros
casse-tête de ouf sur la chaîne comme
celui à 15000 euros de la réponse et
c'est déjà parti en fabrication il va y
avoir des mois de travail dessus donc ça
arrivera en deuxième partie de l'année
sur moi après l'été et c'est donc
attendez-vous à des placements produits
quand même pour financer sa la vidéo
d'aujourd'hui est sponsorisé par lens
mobile qui vous offre l'occasion de
gagner plein de casse tête de la
collection constanta comment celui ci
celui là ou encore celui ci en tout vie
casse tête qui seront offerts à 8
d'entre vous ayant téléchargé et joue
évidemment au jeu via le lien qui se
trouve dans la description
si vous ne connaissez pas encore lors du
mobile sachez que c'est un jeu de
stratégie en temps réel gratuit parmi
les plus populaires au monde dans un
univers médiéval qui a rempli de magie
créatures fantastiques vous allez
pouvoir développer votre royaume votre
armée et même entraîner vos héros
favoris tant sur passer vos ennemis
alors c'est à vous de décider si vous
voulez être un seigneur brutale ou un
fin stratège à la bringue a que la
victoire qui compte
l'éditeur vient aussi d'ajouter un mode
tower defense très excitant qui devrait
ravir les fans de ce type de contenu du
couple six en sont fans sont contents de
le voir en plus le jeu est aussi
généreux en événement choral et
compenser si vous passez par le lien
description pour le télécharger
gratuitement il offre à chaque inscrit
350 euros de cadeaux dans le jeu et la
possibilité donc de gagner un casse-tête
en gros dites vous que tous les joueurs
vont recevoir des tonnes de cadeaux
durant sept jours de suite dans leur
mobile en prime à chaque fois que votre
château va augmenter d'un niveau vous
pourrez tourner la roue de la fortune
sur la page d'événements et avec un peu
de chance vous tomberez sur l'un des
cassettes ou d'autres cadeaux pour
progresser plus vite donc on va pas
tergiverser
beaucoup plus que ça c'est parti donc ce
casse tête et alors il composé d'un truc
en temps normal qu'ils aient mieux faire
mais que ça mais souvenez-vous dans la
vidéo d'il ya cinq mois on l'avait
dépouillé pour un autre casse tête
composé d'un petit bout de clés du reste
j'imagine on va tester de la clé alors
sachez qu'on a quand même été vérifiée
sur le site si c'était normal si ce
n'était pas un souci de départ donc de
cet anneau dépouillé et d'une clé qui
est enfoncée sur lequel n'a pas
forcément si c'est la clé qui ou le
cadenas on est mal
on a ça et ça qui se rejoignent
effectivement vraiment au micro mm ça
fonctionne le trou qui éduque et et là
je pense c'était juste pour passer
l'anneau est ce que c'est la même
typologie clé d'abord ça le côté à la
même taille
sas a la même taille sas a la même
taille même taille même taille donc les
clés on a même taille est-ce que elles
sont identiques aux différentes celle
d'aldi flight attendre six semaines
annonce a pas l'air d'être exactement
les mêmes là on a un comme un petit
escalier
alors que là c'est tout à fait tout à
fait arrondi donc c'est pas la même clé
ok je sors les accessoires doc picking
et puis on louvre mais c'est pas le but
et est ce que là le l'autre bout c'est
la même chose il faut je me méfie parce
que là l'ouverture qui a juste ici juste
là elle me paraissait plus grande que
celle ci alors que pas du tout ça a
l'air d'être exactement les même pas où
il ya à peu près les mêmes les dents
tous au même endroit donc on peut
imaginer qu'ils aient un deux trois
quatre pistons à l'intérieur et c'est
vraiment juste là où c'est un peu
différent en fait c'est cette partie là
des clés qui sont différentes le bas des
clés sinon je pense que c'est un 4
pistons on va y aller à l'arraché on va
essayer ça j'essaye de voir là pour
l'instant si un mouvement quand on
pousse ou pas alors déjà le premier truc
c'est que la clé elles ne rendent pas
dedans là cette partie là là vraiment ça
ça nous embête ce qui fait que quand je
mets là au lieu de s'enfoncer à cause de
ça ça fait ce levier que vous voyez ici
parce qu'elle peut pas rentrer dedans et
dans l'autre sens encore moins me so
valais le coup de l'essayer je sens
qu'on va passer du temps est-ce qu'il
faut se servir de ça non je pense pas ça
c'est vraiment la nos qui tenait bon si
avec ça je fais pas grand chose à un
moment donné il va falloir faire en fait
il va falloir faire un truc que j'ai pas
envie de faire en gros est ce que ça il
faut le leur foncer là dedans
dans ce sens là ça passait dans ce sens
là ça passe donc déjà il ya ça ça c'est
une bonne colin est déjà si ce coin on
est dégoûtés ah non là ils rendent pas
entièrement comme ça c'est intéressant
s'ils rentrent entièrement est-ce que je
peux tourner
[Musique]
ça c'était au cas où pointe ravala mais
si je le lâche dedans et que l'on va
déjà écouté les pistes on n'a jamais
entendu un voilage là je sens un piston
sais comment c'est fait les serrures je
vous faire voir comment c'est fait une
sérieuse
bougez pas j'arrive à bouger projet dis
moi qui tu deviens un voilà je suis allé
chercher un peu de matos je me suis dit
ça pouvait vous intéresser oui j'ouvre
des serrures on en avait déjà fait sur
la chaîne en 2016-2017 ses désirs heures
d'entraînement transparents là où
permettra de voir je suis double serrure
classique qu'on peut trouver dans
n'importe quelle porte et là on a un
cadenas a une âme quand je vous dis que
j'aime savoir comment fonctionnent les
choses c'est pas tant une blague donc
comme vous pouvez le constater à
l'intérieur on a des pistes ont comme ça
sur les ressorts et en fait ces pistes
en son destin vous voyez bien ils sont
plus ou moins bas en fait et quand on
passe vite les salles et fait bouger et
vous voyez que ces pistes ont en fait
ces deux pistons l'un sur l'autre à
chaque fois et en fonction du ressort et
de la taille des pistes ans il faut que
la césure entre les deux là vous voyez
ici il faut qu'elles soient alignés avec
la serrure et c'est ça qui va permettre
de tourner la serrure ce qui fait que si
on met ça ici là dedans par les gens on
va forcer pour tourner en même temps
pour pour pour sentir et offert à mesure
on va ouvrir comme ça
un phare mesure du truc pour pouvoir
ouvrir le canal et là j'en ai quatre
assassins 6 pistons ça ap 5
bonjour oui bien sûr non j'ai pas je pas
abandonné le projet de départ c'est en
train de leur faire voir sur comme on
ouvre un cadenas
ça n'est jamais arrivé de faire voir à
quelqu'un comme on ouvre un cadenas donc
la musique d'un casse-tête non mais
c'est en fait je veux leur montrer ma
théorie sur ce piston et pour ça pour
moi le plus simple est encore faire 20
mai
[Musique]
et voilà comment on joue donc en gros à
chaque fois j'allais au premier tour
dont je forçais ici pour dés qu'il était
coincé tournée d'un tout petit
millimètre le truc pareil pour le 2ème
3ème 4ème le cinquième le sixième non ah
oui c'est un set pistons ben oui c'est
pour ça que je refais le sixième jeu
vettel est septième
bref vous avez compris c'était la petite
explication de comment marche une série
de la gent revient à lui je pense en
tout cas qu'il ya quatre pistons par
rapport à la forme de la clé je pense à
que vous dis je le sors pas de mes
fesses bah vous écoute et là j'essaye de
passer la clé pour entendre les pistons
et comprendre un peu mieux l'intérieur
de ce truc là j'en ai bien un le sang
j'installe kg 2 clics mais je pense que
c'est le même pistons je suis pas sûr
qu'ils aient beaucoup de piston jeu
quand je fais ça j'ai le clic du piston
si j'avance je dis quand même endroit en
fait j'ai le clic retape à la prochaine
la feuillée les foyers bord bailly il
est dedans je peux pas l'enfoncer plus
simple et en même temps je me dis non
ils ont forcément prévu ça il savait
qu'on allait faire ça c'est pas c'est
pas personne n'a de doute sur ce que je
viens de faire quand même tout le monde
aurait fait comme moi qui veux tu peux
pas rappeler d'un bloc entre pride alors
dire ah là là vous savez quoi j'ai mis
le petit bout à l'intérieur de la
serrure et le mec il n'a pas décroché
ingrat avant il fallait absolument pas
chercher enfin pourquoi je fais ça va je
passe un cadenas pas si je suis en train
de chercher à me convaincre que c'est la
bonne piste que j'utilise puisque je
peux le faire tomber des rares fois
qu'on a tapé un cadenas sur la table il
ya cinq mois on a perdu hambourg
d'accord alors je sais pas ce que j'ai
débloqué ou comment je les débloquer
mais là j'ai pu tourner ouvrir pourquoi
ce qu'ils aient un sens un an ou
peut-être à l'été trop enfoncé ou pas
assez enfoncer quelqu'un sait rien donc
c'était comme ça donc la verrouiller la
tacc déverrouiller jeu pour première
étape facile et je peux le laisser
ouvert dans les deux positions
ok donc maintenant l'idée c'est sortir
le petit truc qu'il ya dedans mais
maintenant on a ça et ça ça peut nous
aider loïc je vous propose une
accélération je pense
[Musique]
comme tout bon casse tête au bout d'un
moment quand tu explore toutes les
possibilités tu commences à faire un peu
d'exploration de nouveau j'ai regardé le
pourtour des clés voir s'il y avait un
truc temps mais ça je suis j'ai mon
cerveau est biaisé c'est le sujet du
jour bienvenue dans matière grise je
suis en train de motos manipuler à cause
du bel up qu'on avait fait la fois
d'avant où il y avait un truc dans le
pourtour bref je suis allé là dessus
mais j'ai voulu le sortir
et du coup j'ai fait juste ça et ça ce
délice et ceux de vis plutôt bien là là
quand on est en position fermée cadenas
fermé ce qu'elle cas là on a un petit
trou et je pense vraiment que si on
passe par là je pense qu'on peut faire
tomber le le cas demain oui si c'est ça
ok donc là on a récupéré sa et du coup
avec cette clé là est-ce qu'on peut
ouvrir en ont à merde mais ça casse tout
ma théorie c'est donc la clé elle
s'enfonce dans les deux sens comme ça
oui
et comme certains je sens un ressort de
temps et comme ça va mettre l'argent
tant qu'ils se trompent pourtant à temps
je l'envoyais comment à l'intérieur je
le voyais dans ce sens n'a pas dans ce
sens là oui on aurait tellement bas
qu'il a recraché la clé quoi donc il est
envoyé comme ça c'est comme ça qu'on a
réussi à ouvrir le cadenas et ensuite
comme ça et là sur la surface de lui il
n'y a rien de particulier sur lui non
plus donc je l'envoyais on va dire les
dents vers le dé quoi de dan look un peu
là j'arrive toujours pas à rouvrir la
intéressant parce que là je n'arrive
plus à leur ouvrir
est ce que en fait c'était sain tout à
leur tête ils étaient juste pas assez en
français ah ouais
après avoir tapé que j'avais réussi à
ouvrir sais pas si vous vous souvenez
j'avais fait ça comme ça et après je
l'avais rouvert comme ça bon sert de
cache l1 à temps c'est il doit y avoir
un truc un mouvement de dents qui fait
que ça coince à un moment donné ou pas
bon peu importe là je vais essayer de le
ressortir comme tout à l'heure c'est pas
compliqué une fois qu'on le sait donc
j'ai des partis comme ça donc elle elle
devrait pouvoir l'ouvrir elle a fermé
comme ça et c'est ça qui est pas logique
le piston est forcément de ce côté du
coup ça ça ça n'a pas de sens et
pourtant je sens un se sentit pourtant
insistant sur la shoah là je le sens
pharos à lhassa ouvra [ __ ] donc non
tiens il ya un sens ok je pense qu'il
faut que ce soit comme ça pour que ça
puisse s'ouvrir ou pas [ __ ] c'est
ricky le premier temps que maintenant je
peux pas sortir la clé qui peut sortir
que comme ça parce que là si je mets la
clé là déjà
déjà pour remettre à la situation il
faudrait être comme ça il faudrait que
la clé elle soit là mais là de castet à
le cadenas il est fermé donc je ne peux
pas le faire mais j'ai besoin de
l'ouvrir mais pour l'ouvrir il faut
qu'il soit comme ça mais là si je le
ferme je peux plus remettre reconnaît
sais pas si je préfère pas les boîtes
dans cette can les quelques six ont
refusé toutes les étapes en arrière une
à une
lui toute manière ils seraient visés
17dans et lui cette dent et en fait
c'est juste le problème dans le vélo
[Musique]
alors des mois qu'est ce tu es bien
alors si vous dépassez pas cette blague
un mec il alors je viens maquis psg sont
hyper non non il caché tout et puis il
ya un petit vieux carré puisque les
côtés fait alors mon père et qui fait
vous empêche de change n'a pas fait
alors on cherche on n'a pas le oui je
change mon a pas chez tient les soul et
se prend un truc de la glaciale tard en
emmener sa glacière
c'est bon il m'a saoulé il remballe tout
étouffe qui ne veut alors on arrête de
pêcher oui on arrête de pêcher là on est
vraiment très mal trans en vélo et tout
et puis la [ __ ] ils attaquent la côte
pourront repartir parce que c'était en
bas d'une montagne quand tu as il montre
la côte à côte les vend plus de face et
tout le temps il ya un ras-le bol mettez
énervé par le petit vie en main au bout
d'une demi heure il a fait ce qu'il a pu
quoi tu vois il est en sueur et machin
il regarde c'est la [ __ ] lui va pas me
manquer quoi il voit le petit virbac y
faire un grand geste est ou non elle
laisse tomber à les irp et d'ail en
plateau est un coup d'oeil et petits
vais faire mais on ne sait trop bien
ouais je redescends quoi redescend toute
la montagne et où qu'ils aillent vers le
petit vieux effet barak a oublié quelque
chose n'est fait alors on fait du verrou
secoue alors on règle la caméra alors
alors on va appeler d'autres
alors soyez au montage là il est en
position fermée donc je peux pas leur
rentrer hockey et que ça en position et
du couffo ce genre au des mondes pour
rouvrir et du coup tout ça pour quoi
[ __ ] j'ai cru que j'avais réussi à
atteindre et pour moi ça ça peut passer
voilà monsieur c'est comme ça elle veut
pas à nous dire quelque chose cette clé
là à vouloir aller dans les deux sens
[Musique]
je te jure que je viens de trouver sans
faire exprès dans ce sens là si je mets
pas la clé à fond regardez dans ce sens
là là j'ai enfoncé la clé à l'envers et
sans la faire rentrer à fond juste avant
j'ai un cran où j'arrive à ouvrir et à
sortir
donc à temps parce qu'on n'a pas fini
l'histoire mais effectivement si c'est
ça c'est à présent c'est être changée si
lui là je leur mets comme ça peut-être
je peux refaire mais avec ça loïc je
crois c'est grâce à ta présence
alors on stimule à la résolution du
casse-tête
c'était bien fait et par contre en vrai
je n'ai aucune idée du fonctionnement
l'intérieur et puis là on va avoir du
mal à l'ouvrir super intéressant très
très cool ça chouette
le bien qui j'ai j'ai kiffé au jeu mais
ce casse tête à gagner ou pas sûr alors
genre feront bien sûr le poste qui
apparaît ici là exact il va falloir
qu'on le fasse après des coups si
ballack ne nous ont pas oubliés une note
une note
en vrai un petit vite sur 10 parce que
c'est ma bourgneuf service parce que
parce que c'est rare d'avoir des cadenas
avec autant d'originalité en se disant
mais je n'ai pas compris par contre
comment ça fonctionne et à l'intérieur
donc c'était le cas donc bravo à adan
j'imagine d'un bloc têtes d'ânes qui a
fabriqué sa et on vous met à gagner sur
install le lien dans la description on
vous met également le cadenas dans la
description où vous pouvez le trouver
sûrement chez mes potes de l'insolent je
crois qu'ils ont le dialogue
je vous mets le cil de l'insoluble y a
des questions à des via des chambres et
le site de masen biya des castes être
très très chouette là-bas très original
fuit alors d'abord on se met d'accord
vous et moi si la vidéo vous a plu vous
lalique et ensuite si vous n'êtes pas
abonnés à cette chaîne n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner c'est gratuit moi je
m'appelle toujours pas bien pourquoi je
le répète à chaque fois pour leur ancré
dans vos têtes peut-être mais surtout
parce que j'en ai marre qu'on appelle
sébastien ou olivier olivier olivier on
l'a beaucoup je crois que ça vient de
lui car vraiment le jeune fabien olicard
je vous mets deux autres vidéos ici ici
mais d'abord je voudrais remercier le
partenaire du
jours merci encore à l'heure du mobile
d'avoir sponsorisé cette vidéo
téléchargez le jeu remportée 350 euros
de cadeaux in game et tentez de gagner
un des huit casse tête en faisant
évoluer votre château le lien s'affiche
à l'écran et dans la description et
n'empêche que ce genre de partenariats
qui permettent de financer le prochain
casse tête qui sera pas un 3000 euros
pas 4000 pas signé pas quinze mille on
va voir passer la barre des 20000 look
un peu partenaires gardent pour
compenser sans vouloir vous influencer à
quoi que ce soit mon nouveau livre est
sorti c'est l'anti ride de la
manipulation vous donne le lien dans la
description vous avez aussi la vidéo de
présentation solide de la description
je rend l'antenne à vous les studios
prenez soin de vous ici deux autres
cadenas les anciens de de cadenas et des
cadenas plutôt qu'à des nations comme
kim